AMERICANS WHO SUPPORT THE SECOND
AMENDMENT AND THE NRA.
AND BY THE WAY, THOSE PEOPLE
VOTE, TOO.
AND THAT'S THE ANGLE.
JOINING ME NOW FOR REACTION ARE
TWO CONGRESSMEN FROM THE GOP,
WISCONSIN CONGRESSMAN SEAN DUFFY
AND FROM THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
CALIFORNIA CONGRESSMAN JOHN IN
SACRAMENTO.
LET'S START WITH YOU CONGRESSMAN
DUFFY
DUFF
DUFFY.
THIS NRA BOYCOTT SEEMS TO MISS
THE POINT OF THE RED FLAGS
MISSED BY THE AUTHORITIES AND
ALL THE OTHER FACTORS THAT COME
INTO PLAY.
YOU SAY?
>> THERE'S A WHOLE BUNCH OF
THINGS WE SHOULD LOOK AT.
LET'S LOOK AT WHAT FAILINGS
HAPPENED WITHIN LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT, FAILINGS OF FBI,
THE FAILINGS OF THE SCHOOL THAT
FAILED TO PROTECT THESE KIDS
FROM NIKOLAS CRUZ COMING IN AND
SHOOTING THEM UP.
WHAT YOU SEE HAPPENING ACROSS
AMERICA IS YOU HAVE LEFT-LEANING
MEDIA COMPANIES PUTTING
INCREDIBLE PRESSURE ON COMPANIES
TO BUY IN TO THE LIBERAL AGENDA.
THESE COMPANIES FORGET, THOUGH
THEY MIGHT BE HEADQUARTERED IN
NEW YORK, CALIFORNIA, OR
CHICAGO, THEY TRY TO HOCK THEIR
WARES ALL ACROSS MIDDLE AMERICA.
AND I THINK THOUGH WE MIGHT NOT
SIGN PETITIONS ONLINE TO
BOYCOTT, WE MIGHT NOT COME TO
RALLIES, YOU'LL SEE AMERICANS
OFFENDED BY WHAT THESE COMPANIES
ARE DOING.
I'M GOING TO SPEND MY MONEY WITH
COMPANIES THAT SUPPORT MY
VALUES.
AND I THINK YOU'RE GOING TO SEE
THAT AFFECT THE BOTTOM LINE OF
COMPANIES ALL ACROSS AMERICA,
WHICH WOULD BE A GOOD THING.
>> THE NEW YORK GOVERNOR IS
TRYING TO LURE DELTA TO NEW
YORK, SAYING, COME TO NEW YORK,
WE'LL TREAT YOU WELL.
BUT NEW YORK IS A NIGHTMARE
STILL FOR BUSINESSES, EVEN
THOUGH THEY TRIED TO BRING MORE
BUSINESSES BACK.
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION TO THIS
CONCERN FROM THE NRA MEMBERS AND
JUST REGULAR AMERICANS.
THIS IS TAKING IT A BIT TOO FAR
THAT THE NRA IS KILLING KIDS.
COME ON.
>> WELL, THE REALITY IS THAT
BOYCOTTS FOR POLITICAL AND
ECONOMIC REASONS ARE AS OLD AS
THIS NATION.
IF YOU REMEMBER THE FIRST TEA
PARTY, I MEAN THE BOSTON TEA
PARTY.
THAT WAS A BOYCOTT.
IT GOES ON AND ON IN THIS NATION
WHERE PEOPLE EXPRESS THEIR
POLITICAL OR ECONOMIC VIEWS BY
NOT INVOLVING THEMSELVES WITH
ONE COMPANY OR ANOTHER.
FOR THESE COMPANIES, I THINK THE
WORDS OF THE PRESIDENT OF DELTA
AIRLINES PROBABLY IS WHAT WE
OUGHT TO LOOK AT.
AND THAT IS THAT DELTA, IF I'VE
HEARD HIM CORRECTLY, BASICALLY
SAID THAT THAT COMPANY AND THAT
-- AND HE DOES NOT WANT TO BE
INVOLVED IN A POLITICAL DEBATE
OVER ISSUES THAT ARE NOT
DIRECTLY RELATED TO THAT
COMPANY.
NOW, WITH REGARD TO THE GEORGIA
LEGISLATURE, AND I SUPPOSE THE
GOVERNOR REPEALING THAT SALES
TAX EXEMPTION, I'VE BEEN DOWN
THIS ROAD BEFORE WHERE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA THERE WAS A HUGE
FIGHT BETWEEN THE BAY AREA AIR
FIGHT BETWEEN THE BAY AREA AI
AIRPORTS AND LOS ANGELES OVER
SALES TAX FOR JET FUELS.
SO I THINK DELTA WILL SIMPLY
LOAD ITS PLANES WITH FUEL
SOMEPLACE ELSEWHERE THEY CAN GET
A TAX BREAK.
>> I GET IT.
BUT THE PROBLEM HERE IS THAT THE
MEMBERS OF THE NRA HAD NOTHING
TO DO WITH THIS SHOOTING.
THEY'RE NOT RESPONSIBLE FOR
THIS.
AND TRUTH BE TOLD, I THINK THEY
ONLY HAD LIKE 13 PEOPLE GET THIS
DELTA BREAK ON THEIR AIRFARE TO
THE NRA CONFERENCE.
IT'S NOT THAT MANY PEOPLE.
BUT IT'S A MESSAGE.
AND IT'S THE SAME MESSAGE THAT
MIDDLE AMERICA HAS GOTTEN FROM
THE ELITES FOR YEARS, THAT
YOU'RE STUPID, YOU'RE OBSESSED
WITH GUNS, YOU'RE A BUNCH OF
BIBLE-THUMPING IDIOTS.
THAT'S HOW THEY FEEL.
CONGRESSMAN DID YOU HAVETY  --
DUFFY, I KNOW WE'VE DISCUSSED
THIS BEFORE.
>> I REPRESENT A VERY LARGE
AGRICULTURAL DISTRICT AND
THERE'S NO ONE THAT I'M AWARE OF
IN THE DEMOCRATIC DELEGATION
THAT WOULD EVEN BEGIN TO
DESCRIBE MY AREA AND THE PEOPLE
THAT I REPRESENT IN THE WAY YOU
JUST DID.
>> OKAY, WELL --
>>THEY HAVE THEIR VIEWS.
SOME ARE CONSERVATIVE, SOME OF
LIBERAL, BUT ALL OF THEM BELIEVE
THIS IS AMERICA AND THEY HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK OUT AND
TO --
>>CONGRESSMAN -- AND I WANT
DUFFY TO GET ON THIS.
IF WE'RE GOING TO JUDGE PEOPLE
BASED ON AN ORGANIZATION, BLOOD
SPILLED, WELL, I HOPE PLANNED
PARENTHOOD IS GOING TO LOSE ALL
OF ITS PARTNERSHIPS OR
AFFILIATIONS, GIVEN THE FACT
THAT WE HAVE ABOUT 57 MILLION
BABIES WHO NEVER GOT TO SEE THE
LIGHT OF DAY.
THERE'S A LOT OF MEDICAL WASTE
THAT INCLUDES BLOOD ALL OVER
THIS COUNTRY.
AND SO THE VILIFY THE NRA WHEN
WE HAVE 325,000 BABIES MURDERED
IN A PLANNED PARENTHOOD CLINIC
EVERY YEAR, GIVE ME A BREAK.
>> YOU HEAR THE LEFT WING MEDIA
TALKING ABOUT SAVING KIDS LIVE
AND YOU HEAR THE KIDS TALKING
ABOUT SAVING KIDS LIVES.
I WOULD LIKE TO THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY AND PLANNED PARENTHOOD.
PLANNED PARENTHOOD KILLED 300 OF
THE MOST DEFENSELESS LITTLE
BABIES LAST YEAR ALONE.
300,000, RIGHT.
AND IF YOU WANT TO GO AFTER
GUNS, WHICH A CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHT.
THIS IS THE GREATEST HYPOCRISY
THAT EVER EXISTED.
THEY'RE NOT TRYING TO SAVE
LIVES.
LIBERALS WANT US TO RELY ON
GOVERNMENT, WHETHER IT'S OUR HOW
IS  -- HOUSING, HEALTHCARE,
SECOND AMENDMENT.
THEY WANT ALL RELIANCE OF
GOVERNMENT.
THIS IS ONE MORE STEP TO TAKE
AWAY INDIVIDUAL RIGHTS AND POINT
US TO A GOVERNMENT THAT IS
RESPONSIBLE TO EVERYTHING THAT
WE'LL EVER NEED IN YOUR LIVES.
WE BELIEVE AS REPUBLICANS FOR
INDIVIDUAL RESPONSIBILITY AND
LIBERTY.
I DON'T WANT TO RELY ON LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
AND LIBERALS SAY THEY SHOULD
PROVIDE EVERYTHING TO YOU.
>> THOSE ARE REALLY GOOD
TALKING POINTS, BUT WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE IS REALLY THE
SAFETY IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
AND THERE IS AN APPROPRIATE AND
A VERY GOOD DEBATE GOING ON IN
AMERICA ABOUT WHAT ROLE GUNS
HAVE IN OUR SOCIETY AND HOW WE
COULD BEST PROTECT OURSELVES
INDIVIDUALLY.
>> IF YOU CARE ABOUT LITTLE
KIDS -- DO YOU CARE ABOUT
CHILDREN?
HOW COULD YOU AND YOUR PARTY
SUPPORT PLANNED PARENTHOOD?
YOU CAN'T HAVE IT BOTH WAYS.
>> OKAY, SEAN.
GO AHEAD.
>> WE'RE OUT OF TIME, GUYS.
YEAH.
>> LAURA -- PLANNED PARENTHOOD
IN SOME SEGUE THAT I MISSED.
LET'S GET BACK TO THE ISSUE AT
HAND.
>> LET ME TELL YOU WHY WE SAID
IT.
I THOUGHT IT WAS PRETTY CLEAR,
BUT I'LL EXPLAIN IT AGAIN.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE BLOOD OF
CHILDREN, INNOCENT CHILDREN WHO
WERE GUNNED DOWN IN THAT SCHOOL.
BLOOD OF THE MOST INNOCENT WHO
ARE DEFENSELESS IN THE WOMB.
THE ELDERLY, IN THE WOMB, AND
THE DISABLED ARE THE MOST
DEFENSELESS IN THIS COUNTRY.
THAT'S WHY HE BROUGHT IT UP.
BUT GO AHEAD.
>> LAURA, IF YOU COULD JUST
SLOW DOWN FOR A FEW MOMENTS,
PLANNED PARENTHOOD GETS NO MONEY
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
>> HALF A BILLION DOLLARS,
OKAY.
THEY GET NO MONEY?
WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT?
THEY GET HALF A BILLION DOLLARS.
>> IF YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THE ABORTION ISSUE, WE CAN DO
THAT ALSO.
BUT WE STARTED THIS CONVERSATION
--
>>IT MAKES YOU UNCOMFORTABLE.
BUT GO AHEAD.
>> PLEASE DON'T PUT WORDS IN MY
MOUTH.
>> I'M NOT.
THAT'S AN OPINION.
BUT GO AHEAD.
>> WE HAVE BEFORE US IN
WASHINGTON A VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUE.
AND THAT IS HOW ARE WE GOING TO
DEAL WITH THE GUN VIOLENCE IN
OUR NATION, WHETHER BY SUICIDE
IN INDIVIDUAL HOMES OR WHETHER
IT IS BY ASSAULT WEAPONS AS WE
SAW AT THE SCHOOLS.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT DEBATE.
AND WE OUGHT NOT MOVE AWAY FROM
THAT DEBATE ONTO OTHER ISSUES
WHICH ARE IMPORTANT ALSO.
SO LET US GO BACK TO THIS ISSUE.
HOW ARE WE GOING TO DEAL WITH
THIS?
>> OKAY.
A LOT OF PEOPLE WANT TO TAKE
AWAY GUN RIGHTS.
I GET THAT.
THAT'S AN OLD DEBATE.
BUT WE HAD THE FBI AND LOCAL
AUTHORITIES AND THE SCHOOL
ITSELF REFUSING TO ACT ON THE
OBVIOUS FOR A LOT OF DIFFERENT
REASONS.
AND MAYBE IT WAS MALFEASANCE.
MAYBE IT WAS A MISTAKE OR AN
OVERSIGHT.
BUT THOSE THREE FACTORS ALONE
COMBINE TOGETHER TO ALLOW THIS
KID TO GET THESE WEAPONS.
IT WASN'T THE NRA WHO MISSED THE
RED FLAG.
THE FBI WERE TOLD THE KID'S
GOING TO SHOOT UP THE SCHOOL AND
THEY DON'T STOP THEM, AND
SUDDENLY IT'S THE NRA'S PROBLEM.
YOU'VE GOT TO BE KIDDING ME.
THAT'S A LAME ARGUMENT.
>> WE'VE HAD GUNS IN OUR
SOCIETY SINCE OUR FOUNDING.
AND KIDS WEREN'T PICKING UP GUNS
AND SHOOTING OTHER KIDS IN
SCHOOLS.
WHAT'S HAPPENED THAT'S CAUSED
THIS PHENOMENON TO TAKE PLACE?
FATHERLESS HOMES, VIOLENCE THAT
COMES FROM HOLLYWOOD, WE HAVE A
SLEW OF ISSUES THAT HAVE TAKEN
PLACE THAT HAVE UNDERMINED OUR
FAITH AND VALUES.
YOU COULD LOOK AT A WHOLE SUBSET
OF ISSUES THAT ARE ADDRESSING
THE ANGER THAT KIDS HAVE RIGHT
NOW THAT CAUSE THEM TO PICK UP
GUNS.
THERE'S A DETACHMENT WE HAVE.
>> SEAN, YOU'RE QUITE CORRECT.
>> LAST WORDS.
>> YOU'VE BEEN DRIVEN FOR 20
YEARS THAT WILL COME UP WITH
EACH NEW SHOOTING.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS WE HAVE A
CRISIS IN AMERICA AND IT'S NOT
GUNS.
IT'S OUR CULTURE AND THE WAY
WE'RE RAISING OUR KIDS.
>> YOU'VE RAISED A VERY VALID
POINT.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
NEED TO DO IS TO USE TOOLS THAT
ARE READILY AVAILABLE AND HAVE
BEEN AVAILABLE FOR SOME TIME TO
BE USED IN SCHOOLS TO DEAL WITH
THOSE PRECISE ISSUES THAT YOU
RAISE.
THAT IS THE ACTING OUT, THE
LONELINESS THAT SOME PEOPLE HAVE
AND THE ISOLATION AND BULLYING
THAT DOES TAKE PLACE.
COMING OUT OF COLUMBINE AS WELL
AS SANDY HOOK ARE TWO SUCCESSFUL
PROGRAMS AVAILABLE IN SCHOOLS.
IT IS INTERESTING TO NOTE THAT
IN THE PRESIDENT'S BUDGET, HE
REMOVED SOME $50 MILLION DOLLARS
FOR SAFE SCHOOLS, TO DEAL WITH
THOSE PROBLEMS THAT YOU JUST
DESCRIBED.
SO WE AULTH
SO WE AULT
SO WE OULT
SO WE OUGH
SO WE OUGHT
SO WE OUGHT TO
SO WE OUGHT TO G
SO WE OUGHT TO GET
SO WE OUGHT TO GET A
SO WE OUGHT TO GET ABO
SO WE OUGHT TO GET ABOUT
SO WE OUGHT TO GET ABOUT D
SO WE OUGHT TO GET ABOUT DOI
SO WE OUGHT TO GET ABOUT DOING
THAT.
>> WE'RE WAY OVER THE SEGMENT,
BUT GO AHEAD.
>> LET'S TAKE SOME OF THAT $63
MILLION.
WE BOTH AGREE WE NEED SCHOOL
SECURITY.
YOU MIGHT SAY, I WANT AN ARMED
LAW-ABIDING TEACHERS WHO HAVE
SPECIFIC TRAINING.
LET'S FOCUS ON THE THINGS WE CAN